Aaron Sampson here emerging from two
weeks of playing destiny and raising a
newborn baby even though I had my hands
full of blue purple and greenish brown
n-grams yeah I still manage to do some
non destiny related shooting of which
I'm about to tell you the first thing
happened in battlefield 4 now in its
terminal stage I mean final stand stage
which came out with four playable maps
in their community test environment I'm
happy to say that map design in
battlefield 4 keeps getting better and
better if naval strike was the aquatic
dlc final stand would be the
subterranean dlc almost every map having
it built out bunker complex that leads
to intense infantry combat and also adds
tactical death you control the interior
of the map on foot or do you control the
exterior with vehicles to really cool
map features that stood out were first
off on hangar 21 a massive hangar where
a titan is under construction not to
mention this big-ass engine testing
exhaust port underneath and the other
particularly cool feature was on the
giants of Corellia map and involved a
giant collapsible ceiling that makes up
for one not being an operation Locker
and in case you missed it this thematic
dlc is a prequel to battlefield 2142
future weapons also abound in final
stand you've got a hover tank which at
this stage seems to be kind of like a
just hard to control tank you've got the
xt-1 minigun UAV which reigns death from
the sky you have the SC 42 which is a
bullet spewing monster that also
hilariously juggles vehicles in the
alpha and you've got pod launchers on
hangar 21 that allow players to leapfrog
up and down the mountainside I think I'm
forgetting something oh yeah the railgun
Q silly music
I need to work on that one a bit my
overall early impressions of final stand
is that it looks like enough new content
for players to return to battlefield 4
for one last hurrah I respect dice for
going back to thematic DLC in future
weapons because at least did something
different with battlefield 4 wrapping up
all I have to say is the next
battlefield had better launch on a
stable platform get rid of the painful
scoop unlock grinding system ditch that
god-awful Battle Pack fiasco and stop
reusing assets for me to even consider
it moving on to the other game I played
last week
the other thing that you may have missed
in the destiny hype week is titanfall
dropped its last DLC titled IMC rising
I've made no secret of my love for this
game it's rare that a developer says
something like 6v6 no trust us and
people react skeptically then they prove
everyone wrong more than any other
shooter in recent memory titanfall
nailed basic shooting and movement
mechanics while making conscious
decisions like everyone gets a Titan the
ability to eject the smart pistol and
grunts to make sure anyone at any skill
level can have fun IMC rising continues
in the tradition of stellar map design
exciting Titan fights and fantastic park
or rather than talk a lot about this
last DLC I'd rather leave on a few
thoughts for titanfall sequel the next
titanfall should push the multiplayer
campaign much further and not be afraid
to get players involved directly in plot
points this means that unlike in the
first titanfall the game can't be afraid
of having campaign winners and campaign
losers also the campaign shouldn't be
afraid to include a PVE aspect shoot a
dragon you should draw aggro shoot a
big-ass brontosaurus and maybe even
encourage both teams to pause fighting
to handle a greater threat the next
titanfall should also distinguish the
two sides better militia needs to have
more beat up more jury-rigged titans in
gear also the black market system
implemented in frontiers edge should
lead to extremely unique weapons and
equipment which it doesn't go nearly far
enough on at present finally titanfall
hints at so much lower between matches
it's clear that it exists respawn should
cough it up alright well back to destiny
until Borderlands pre-sequel launches
next month be sure to check out the
hilarious playing is for claptraps in
borderland the pre-sequel video on
gamespot extra points if you find the
flappy birds reference Aaron out
you